[Musik]
amerika ist auf den barrikaden steckt
mitten in einem kultur kampf um die
zukunft der stärksten demokratie der
welt
wollt ihr die kanzel karte der
kosmopolitischen elite von nancy pelosi
chuck schumer und joe biden wurde bitte
ich kämpfen manche gegen die veränderung
schrecken dabei auch vor gewalt nicht
zurück wenn das kleine kämpfe katar ist
was dann
es ist ein kampf um die zukunft an die
mittlerweile alle gruppen der
gesellschaft beteiligt sind
sport wirtschaft politik und auch die
hochschule per videochat haben wir uns
mit greg pattern verabredet professor an
der masch ob business school der
renommierten university of southern
california
er wurde vergangenes jahr opfer einer
besonders absurden attacke der vorwurf
soll absichtlich ein rassistisches
schimpfwort in böser absicht benutzt
haben und angeblich versucht haben bis
zu vertuschen
die studierenden sollten nicht mehrfach
gebeten haben das wort nicht mehr zu
sagen doch nichts davon ist wahr in
einer digitalen vorlesung zu
wirtschaftskommunikation spricht er über
füllwörter in verschiedenen kulturen er
nutzt unter anderem auch ein beispiel
aus china
wyss im bett dies und das
je nach muttersprache könnte das so
klingt da da da da im chinesischen wäre
das in die kategorie gab es gibt dafür
verschiedene worte in verschiedenen
ländern
die können dann so klingen da da da mm
oder rs3 studenten fühlen sich durch das
chinesische beispiel rassistisch
gekränkt und beleidigt beschweren sich
bei der universität
der dekan der fakultät reagiert ohne
rücksprache mit petn sofort mit einer e
mail und nimmt ihm den kurs ab
vergangenen donnerstag hat professor
greg patton in seiner klasse mehrfach
ein chinesisches wort verwendet das so
ähnlich klingt wie eine üble
rassistische beleidigung
verständlicherweise hat das großen
schmerz und ärger unter den studenten
hervorgerufen
und das tut mir sehr leid es ist für
unsere fakultät schlicht und einfach
unakzeptabel in unseren kursen worte zu
verwenden die leid und kummer
hervorrufen und die psychologische
sicherheit der studenten beeinträchtigen
wir müssen und werden uns besser solche
anschuldigungen haben an amerikanischen
universitäten stark zugenommen
der frühere us-präsident barack obama
ist besorgt und meldet sich zu wort
da gibt es diese einstellung dass sich
veränderungen herbeiführen kann indem
ich über andere so rasch wie möglich
urteil und das reicht wenn ich darüber
twittere wie du etwas falsch gemacht
hast oder die falschen worte verwendet
hat dann lehne ich mich zurück und fühle
mich gut wie vogue wie wachsam ich bin
ich hab dich erwischt mehr als 150
intellektuelle linke und konservative
sind besorgt über den trend zu
diffamieren stadt zu diskutieren und
haben einen offenen brief geschrieben
rufen auf zu diskurs und toleranz
mit dabei noam chomsky francis fukuyama
der jazztrompeter wynton marsalis
schriftsteller salman rushdie und jackie
rowling auch loretta ross aktivistin und
professoren am renommierten smith
college ich habe den brief
unterschrieben denn ich denke wir sind
zu weit gegangen auf der linken wie auf
der rechten seite wir haben unsere
fähigkeit zum dialog verloren
viel zu schnell dämonisieren wir andere
weil sie uns nicht beipflichten
ganz so als würden wir einen kult
gründen aber wir wollen kein kult
schaffen sondern einen
menschenrechtsbewegung und per
definition brauchen wir dafür die
diversität der meinungen und gedanken
denn diversität bringt mehr in den pool
und du kommst mit besseren ideen wieder
raus das problem aber sei nicht neu
amerika befindet sich in einem ständigen
kulturkampfes & culture gebe es schon
seit den 50er jahren
es war schon immer da du erinnerst dich
vielleicht an die 50er jahre in den
senator mccarthy fielen die hollywood
karriere zerstört hatte indem er sie als
kommunisten beschuldigte das gibt es
schon eine ganze weile
heute wird kanzel kalter von beiden
seiten als waffe benutzt von der linken
li von der rechten die politische rechte
nutzt die methode kerze culture um
kritik und diskurs zu unterdrücken um
ihre vormachtstellung in der
gesellschaft zu verteidigen
sie rufen auf sportler zu entlassen
deren kritik nicht in ihr weltbild passt
und konzerne zu boykottieren die sich
gegen ihre politik stellen minderheiten
das wählen zu erschweren
und sie gehen noch einen schritt weiter
behaupten selbst opfer der politischen
korrektheit einer linken
meinungsdiktatur zu sein meint die
bloggerin am ende die konservativen
wollen sich als opfer sehen denn das
macht sie zu den helden der geschichte
so sind sie die unterdrückten
sie erzählen sich gegenseitig diese
geschichten der sie nicht mehr vor
weihnachten sagen oder keine hamburger
messen dürfen
das sind alles lügen so aber machen sie
dich selbst zu den guten in der
geschichte und die liberalen zu den
bösen die sozialen medien millionenfach
geteilt erzählen sie sich dass die
radikale linke ihn die wahlen gestohlen
hat so machen sie sich zum opfer einer
verschwörung dienen dann alles erlaubt
auch den gewaltsamen stürmung des
kapitols auf geheiß von ihrem anführer
der millionen stimmen gegen ihn für
ungültig erklären lassen
wenn du versuchst den menschen ihre
stimme zu nehmen ist das die beste
definition von cancel culture denn du
sagst damit deine meinung deine rechte
deine teilnahme spielt in unserem
politischen system keine rolle
und wie sie das der wirtschaftsprofessor
der seinen kurs verloren hat manche
schießen übers ziel hinaus in meinem
fall auf lächerliche weise aber mehr zur
verantwortung gezogen werden für das was
man tut ist eigentlich gut denn licht
vertreibt die dunkelheit
cancel culture sei vor allem ein begriff
der von denen verwendet werden die
sozialen fortschritt aufhalten wollten
die unfähigkeit zum dialog aber ist eine
gefahr für die amerikanische demokratie
die mitten in einem kulturkampf um ihre
zukunft steckt